One of the great challenges in medicine,
especially in the modern era is
the healthcare leader,
is trying to balance big data,
cutting edge research with a fundamental
sense of caring for the patient.
How do you deliver the sense of care and
caring while still delivering
cutting edge science?
[MUSIC]
>> I knew that anything that involved
Stanford GSB, the design school,
was going to be something that was really
going to challenge your mind in a new way,
not your typical leadership program.
And then when I saw that it had the
interdisciplinary work with the medical
school, I'd felt like it was my
life wrapped up in a program.
>> The Innovative Healthcare
Leader Program is a new offering
here at Stanford University that's offered
jointly between the School of Medicine,
and the Graduate School of Business.
>> The Innovative Healthcare Leader
is tremendously exciting for me,
because we're really capturing a synergy
that is everything that Stanford's about.
>> Abraham said something in one of
his lectures that has stuck with me,
which was that the Stone Age didn't
end because we ran out of stones.
And as I am thinking about things changing
in medicine it's not that the things we
have aren't working,
it's just new things keep coming.
>> One of the goals of
the 21st century leader is to
remove the impediments to creativity,
remove the impediments to innovation.
And this course is really
about understanding
what elements in your culture or
perhaps even in your own personality or
in your workplace are actually preventing
you from allowing innovation to happen.
>> One of the great strengths
of the Graduate School of
Business is the way that they've
championed design thinking.
>> The D school's unique.
That was one of the wonderful
parts of this program.
It helped strip us down a little bit.
The team approach, coming together
with people that you didn't know and
through the process of working together
here we challenged each other and
came up with different ways
of thinking of a problem.
The design thinking methodology allows
us to break big problems down into
small manageable chunks, and
then innovate to develop solutions for
those problems in a way that
feels much less overwhelming.
>> We're on the edge of
this destructive industry.
And it's really helpful to
step back from that a bit and
focus on strategies to be even
more effective in that role.
>> I'm leading a program that has grown
dramatically over the past two years.
I really hadn't thought about
some of the challenges that
would come up in that process, and I feel
like I'm going back with some tools to
better manage that change now and to help
my team better be a part of that process.
>> A bit of compass resetting is
an important part of the week here.
So at the same time that it does
represent an investment in time,
the return on that investment is
the chance to rethink the direction that
you're moving in in your institution or
in ones hospital or workplace.
>> The healthcare leader of the future
needs to worry about the patient, but
also about the welfare of
the people taking care of them.
Nothing else is going to work
if your workforce is unhappy.
>> This intersection of some of the best
minds in medicine and some of the best
minds in business will offer healthcare
leaders tools for leadership and
innovation to manage change in this
ever-changing healthcare environment.
How do we keep that art in medicine?
How do we keep that patient contact
in spite of all this technology and
things that are being pulled from us?
>> I think there's a gap between
our intent and the actual execution
between the wonderful technology
we have and the fundamental sense.
As Peabody said many,
many years ago that the secret of the care
of the patient is in caring for
the patient.
[MUSIC]